nobody likes you no one likes you but
you I haven't you do survive pretty well
you'd be better off being a javelina
what's a javelina it's a peccary
what's a peccary it's like a cousin to a
pig what's a pig lives you know Doug
lives in Bisbee Arizona who by the way I
think it's so it sold out but he's
taping his uh his next special in Vegas
next month oh nice yeah in Vegas that's
cool where he lives in Bisbee like he
basically that's that's a javelina he
lives real on the border like I think
he's only like six miles from the border
some crazy shit and these things live in
the wild out in the desert right fucking
there
aggressive ooh and they fucked up his
neighbor's dog they killed his
neighbor's dog yeah yeah man the dog was
out and the javelinas will flank it like
to get on both sides of it and they hums
like in a pack yeah they hunt in a pack
and they will attack a small dog ooh
that thing's disgusting yeah they're
gross that's that's like a giant rat it
looks like a giant rat well it does it
looks like a pig fuck - Rhett oh so many
shopping at Facebook Oh Ross Bo people
hunt them all the time looks like a pig
fucked a rat
hey see that got shot one doesn't go
your Pig fuck - right yeah click on the
guy who shot one yeah bow and arrow a
lot of guys hunt them with archery
equipment see wouldn't it be better if
he was dressed in like a dog coat with a
tie none of those boots no I don't want
that thing to see you look at that
that's a rat face throw that is rats
epic shirt that on a giant body screw
scroll back to that last one and make it
bigger again yeah bro that guy's hunting
rats Steve that's like a slightly
different looking rat oh you want to
know what's really giant rat that's a
hundred pound rat yeah without a tail
it's so gross and you know what's really
crazy is those are animals they'll
they're the best animal to a call now
what a call is is like you made a make a
sound of a wounded animal no you make
like
[Music]
like something that's suffering look
like people take their hand these
fuckers
run in they run in real yes they're so
aggressive it's crazy they think
something's hurt and I can go eat it
they but they have to act quick because
there's coyotes out there and mountain
lions out there so when something's
hurtin like fuck food and they just run
towards it so when you're bowhunting you
almost have to have one person make the
call and you're at full draw and then
they start calling and the things come
running in and you shoot at them yeah
because you couldn't do it you couldn't
get to the bow one time because they'd
see you know you'll fuck it's a guy turn
off the other way again yeah are these
like invasive are they all over he's
already know they're natural there's no
but I mean are they not invasive but I
mean is there a lot of them yes there's
like a ton around they exist yeah I mean
they exist in the desert I mean they
they exist in healthy enough populations
you people hunt for them Wow
and they eat them they say oh yeah I
wouldn't eat that but you eat eat a pig
yeah but they're cuter wild boar yeah
crazy tusks looking yeah those are gross
pretty gross my pigs my Kingsley those
the ones I eat have bow ties it's
climbing around this guy's garage in
little tap shoes who the shit bro
there's Stan I'm down there in his
garage there's a whole bunch of em fuck
is that
alright on your kid's toy look at this
it's all it's hairs up Oh anyway look at
that it's just gonna take a dump in your
driveway who'd you do not want that in
your life I don't want to live there
there's fucking 20 of them in this guy's
driveway see that one there in the back
how many grow that back again how many
were there there was like twelve what is
the name of that video for people wanna
watch it
wild javelinas make a visit to Arizona
home I know you can't show those fucking
things are everywhere there's a lot of
them with the white I have a lead how
many of them there are at least eight
and then there's the one that was on top
of the there's nine and then there's the
one that was on top of the truck and
there's one
that you can see through the fence yeah
and there's probably more out there oh
it's gone in the car it's going into the
kids little car Jesus Christ no it's in
the passenger seat of the car
Oh gross fucking I feel like wild
javelina is like a Dean Martin song you
think so man they're weird-looking too
they look like they're demons I don't
like them at all a little beady eyes
like they're up to no good
but a little kid you're thinking like a
why I wouldn't live there because that's
there but if you live in New York you at
night who knows what's climbing all
around your building right oh could be
Eagles and shit right so we're talking
about Oh Google get into my house in
Google javelina eats baby let's see if
that's ever happened
yeah human baby let's see if that
happened what do you think if I have
Alina ate a human yeah like you see
those fucking things yes 20 in that
guy's trial they're definitely eating
babies I'm exaggerating wasn't 20
someone's eating the baby right now
probably 30 it was probably 12 baker's
dozen a baker's dozen of javelinas yeah
they would eat a baby
a toddler yeah knock it down yeah I mean
if they eat a dog yeah they're scared of
people they were obviously weren't
scared of that dude now that's a
full-blown person and a baby doesn't the
bird doesn't have anything I know I put
it to hair up spikes up to let you know
it's threatened did I ever tell you the
story when I pulled a rat out of my pool
vacuum yeah was it alive
no did stink it did it stunk
I'm like why isn't the vacuum working
did you think about a divine and I
pulled it up and there was a half a rat
its ass sticking out the vacuum and as
soon as I got it above the water flies
just pull it out without it there's a
quaking where the fuck are the Flies
before the shit good question
where the fuck are they all over there
not that many like if you if you're
around by a person's backyard
yeah how often is he fly
now and then there's one it's kind of
annoying but if you just pull your pants
down shat on the ground flies on that
was it a batter of muffins oh you mean
right after I swam yeah right after you
swam chef right under law I mean you're
after swim shit yeah yeah and then all
of a sudden they show up yeah it's
disgusting it happened so fast so gross
all of a sudden they're all over yeah
where'd you guys come from we should
just stay inside well did you find a
baby death from a javelina a couple of
months ago it's not a couple people in
Arizona we're attacked and they had like
Oh maaaan was bit while she was walking
her dogs another guy was bit while he
was feeding them and he didn't feed it
fast enough and admit him that's about
as much like a fine well the lady who
got bit that's the scary one because the
guy who fed him as an asshole Yeah right
the scary one there was a lady got bit
by a coyote recently in Dallas oh yeah
no no yeah I was around the Dallas area
I think they think that this is one
coyote that's been biting people it's a
rogue unusual coyote just snapping at
people
oh really yeah they had bite marks on
their legs oh my god yeah it's gross man
because they will kill you
yeah they would kill you they're just
small they're just not sure if it's
worth the effort
and you're around people and they're
worried that you know one on one cuz you
fight off a coyote I don't know if you
could I mean I think you probably could
if you had to but they'll fuck you up
man just keep buying if there's a few of
them that's where the real problem comes
they bite you in the right spot yeah man
the rip your tendons apart you won't be
able to run away they know what they're
doing to know they try to take your legs
out and they know what they're doing
they're not gonna try to jump up and
bite you in the neck they're gonna try
to take your your hamstrings out right
yeah trying to rip your legs apart so
you can't run okay so mean that's how
they're alive
you're not leaving any food out for them
are you no I've got to do what they got
to do it's called domestication that's
how we have dogs you ever take your
family camping I have not yeah I haven't
either I would though I wanted to take
my kids to Yosemite because I love
Yosemite to bring a peace sign armed
nothing just went solo we weren't
killing we're staying in and we're
staying in an inn
what about emergency food no my phone
nothing oh just a phone first-aid kit
a bag of Funyuns and an iPhone mmm
that's all you need and I want to show
them you 70 because it's such a great
part of my life I love it I've been
lived in the backcountry for like a week
at a time I just love the whole thing
and I'm telling them about and I'm
building it up they're like you know we
grudgingly going they're all vegetarians
they just love nature they just love
whatever so I'm like you're gonna love
Yosemite who's we drove into the park
welcome to Yosemite I ran over a
squirrel the horror inside the car
dad you didn't even slow down what's
wrong you're a monster
I'm like I can't it's two lanes there's
a guy behind me a kind front I just
would steamroll the squirrel
they were so they were in the whole
weekend any time I'd be like look at
this look at this beautiful view
you killed a squirrel you didn't even
care that's the weird part Dane you
didn't even care is that what this hand
yeah we're supposed to cry I was just
laughing right like a bitch exactly
that's why he killed a deer you'd be
sadder right yeah damn I can't believe
she was so nice with a little lies and a
little tail but it's grow up peccary
yeah if you killing them javelinas he's
a fucking rat thing find its mom
then javelina would ruin your that much
to bite your teeth could probably use
its teeth to tear your tires apart and
be stuck in the side of the road trying
to change the tire you turn around
there's a whole pack of them closing in
on you would you not take your family
because of all of this
revenge do you not want them in the
woods with you what am I in the woods
well become a werewolf what the fuck you
just got to not your night trust me
I'll be right back not that you're the
threat run that you'd have to protect
them from all the threats well I mean
Yosemite doesn't have that many threats
other than people bears they have black
bears then yeah most of mountain lion
mountain lions are an issue
there's always something out there yeah
grizzly bears or you just you just don't
feel like that's a because you like
going out in the nature you go I do it
stuff I do like one of the nature I also
like being indoors like sleeping in a
place where it's awesome asleep people
wiser than me and figured out that that
maneuver is called a bed with a roof and
a locked door and a refrigerator you
fucking cave person oh I'm gonna rough
it I'm gonna sleep on the ground you
don't have to did you know that if you
sleep in a house